- Welcome everyone. It's another Saturday.
This means another coffee
break here on my channel
Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich and
today I want to talk about
a piece of advice that I
got from one of my mentors
when I worked at McKinsey.
And it was one of the pieces of advice
that were most influential,
the most impactful to my
career as a consultant
when I spent six years at McKinsey.
And even as of today, when I work today
in the PropTech company in Munich
in the position of a
chief revenue officer,
I still think about that and
it's still important to me.
So I want to dig into this with you today.
I will keep this video a
bit more conversational,
a bit less edited, so let
me know in the comments
whether you like this
new or different style.
Would be very interested
to hear your feedback.
And here this comes really
from the perspective
of a young consultant,
someone who starts out at a
firm like McKinsey, BCG, Bain,
or any of these other
management consulting firms.
And what this mentor of mine
told me is that there are
three stages that you progress through
that you can develop yourself
into as a consultant.
And most people start at this first stage,
but people will very quickly find out
that in this first stage, you
will just not be successful
as a consultant.
So then you, at some point, you graduate
into this second stage and then
later into this third stage.
So let's look into these stages.
What do people do and why
are certain of these things
not really helpful, not really good?
Will really limit your career
if you're not realizing this
and if you're not able to at some point
move up these stages.
The first stage is the stage
of a data gatherer, right?
So this is the mindset that
many young consultants have,
that maybe you got a task
from your project leader,
from your partner, to go out there
and conduct certain analysis.
And now, you know,
therefore these analysis
for this piece of work
that you need to do,
you maybe need certain
data or certain information
and you know that there
are these specific clients
that would have this information.
So you go out there, you sit
together with these people,
and you want to do your best
to collect exactly this data
that you are looking
for to do the analysis,
to do the work that you need to do.
So you are a data gatherer.
You are treating your
clients as a source of data,
a source of information that you just need
to sit together with,
and then hopefully you will
get all the information out.
Of course, what is the problem with that?
The issue with that is
that these relationships
that you will build with clients,
if you follow this mindset,
this way of working,
these relationships are
highly transactional.
You treat your counterpart,
your client counterpart,
not really as someone you're
interacting with at eye level,
but rather just as a source of data.
And clearly this often does not
feel great for your clients.
It's not a great experience.
And from your perspective,
it's just your job.
You're doing your job.
You need this information
and you might even complain
or not understand if you're
not getting all the data
that you need from the client,
or you feel like he or she
is not sharing something with you.
You might go even to your project sponsor
and complain about the person and so on.
So these are behaviors of
these more junior consultants,
which clearly are not really helpful.
And I will now reflect when we talk about
the next two stages why this is the case.
And one other key problem
here is that by this way,
you're really not using the opportunity
of getting more information, more insights
out of your client,
besides the very specific
things that you will ask them.
Because once a client realizes
that you are just treating
him or her as a data source,
often these people will just
only share exactly the things
that you asked them to share.
But clearly, often these
people know much more,
many more insights that
would be very helpful to you.
And this is then where the
second stage comes into play.
And this mentor of mine,
this other partner that
gave me this insight,
he called this stage the
stage of co-creation.
So often, usually around
like one year or so,
some people understand this
earlier, others more later,
at some point you will realize
that this way of working
is not really successful, right?
This is just not how it works.
What you want to do instead
is to co-create solutions
with your clients, right?
So of course, at some point
you will ask your clients
also for information and for data,
but this is not the main purpose
of you interacting with them.
Instead, you want to talk
to them and treat them
as someone at eye level
with whom you can co-create
the solutions with.
You don't want to fall into
the mindset that you collect
all the data, then you sit
alone in your team room
or at home, at home office.
And then you prepare some
analysis, crunch the numbers
for weeks, and then after several weeks,
you go back to the client and show him,
wow, this is what I created.
Isn't that amazing?
Isn't that a great piece of
work that I accomplished here?
This is just often not what works well.
Maybe it's even correct,
but if the clients feel like
this is not really something
where they had also opportunity
to partake in the whole ideation process,
if it's not really something
where they at least feel like
they also had some buy-in,
they also had some input
that they could give,
this often does not go away.
At the end of the day, the perfect idea,
the perfect solution,
is not really valuable
if the client organization
is not buying it.
If in the end, the client
organization is not acting on it.
So really think hard about how can you
co-create the solutions with these people?
Are there some great
effective workshop formats
you can have together with these people?
I even saw setups where
we shared our team room
in consulting with a
couple of our key clients.
We really work together
with them every single day,
got their input, involve them in all our
also internal problem solving meetings.
These are the situations
where often you really form
very deep bonds with your
clients over the months
that the project that goes on.
You will get ideally their full buy-in.
They will feel like
everything that you created
was also co-created by them.
And ideally it is not even you in the end
presenting the results of the project
to your project stakeholders,
to your project owners.
What I've seen often, really
it's extremely powerful,
if it's the clients that
you work together with,
if it's them that then
stand in front of the board
and present the results,
present the outcomes of the project.
And of course it is clear that
you as the consulting firm
will then also be part of the meeting,
that you show you also
contributed to that.
But also for them, for the clients,
this is a great opportunity
to show what you created,
to show that they were proud of that,
that they also contributed to that.
It increases their visibility
in the organization.
And by the way, if you don't
know what visibility is
and why it's so important,
I have a rather old,
but I think still very
relevant video on the topic.
I will link it somewhere above here,
but this often turns your
clients into the stars,
into the successful heroes of the project.
And this surely is a
way better way of really
building relationships with the clients
as just treating them as a data source.
But this is not necessarily
the end of this evolution
of a consultant.
Ideally, at some point you
are able to reach stage three.
And this is usually only
where you achieve this
as a senior project lead.
And then of course,
ideally at a partner stage
where you turn into something,
which this mentor of mine
that gave me this insight,
which is called the trusted advisor.
This is, if you want to say it this way,
the last and final evolution
stage of a consultant.
As a trusted advisor,
your client seeks you out
not only for the very specific project
that you are conducting,
but also for any other question
that is relevant and important,
that is top of mind for the client.
You really positioned yourself as a person
who can really add value to any of these
business discussions that you're having.
And often you have very great
and significant opportunities
as a consultant,
especially in the model
where you're working on-site
together with the client.
You really sit together with
your clients every single day.
And even, at least as a project lead,
you will often have the
opportunity to talk to
the senior project sponsors,
which might be board members,
or at least senior business unit heads
or some equivalence of that.
You will have opportunities
to sit with these people
once per week, twice per
week, and talk to them.
And very often, if you have
conversations with them,
they will share also other
issues that they're having,
other challenges that they are facing
beyond the strict scope of your project.
These are often opportunities
for you to pick that up,
to offer some insights,
go to them and say,
hey, I understand that
this is really something
that's bothering you.
Why don't we sit together next week
and I will compile some knowledge,
some insights from that
of our expert networks,
of our insights that we have at the firm.
Let me connect you to
another expert that we have
in our firm that works
specifically on the topic.
Let me reach out to this
person, see what I can do here.
Try to help these people left and right.
And ideally at some point,
whenever these people have a problem,
they will think of you.
They will treat you as
their trusted advisor.
They will invite you
to lunch or to dinner,
or maybe you invite them
to lunch and to dinner.
And you talk about these things
and you offer your insights,
offer your recommendations.
And this, of course, is
the basis of a successful
long-term career in professional services.
I would argue this is true,
not only for consulting,
but also for investment banking
and many other professional
services areas as well,
but you really create a relationship
with one of your clients,
which goes far beyond
just the strict boundaries
of a specific project.
So these are the three
stages that most consultants
go through.
So you start as a data gatherer,
you develop into a co-creator,
and then at some point,
hopefully eventually you
become a trusted advisor
of some of your clients.
And of course, if you're now
starting out in consulting,
ask yourself, what can
you do to really co-create
your solutions more with the
client to get their buy-in,
to align ideas and your
thoughts with them,
to really make them part of the process?
Do not just treat them as a data source.
And frankly, being able
to do that, you showing
that you can do that is often
also one of the main things
that consulting firms look out for
around your first year or
so when the first decisions
are due to promote you to the
next stage, to the next level.
These are really the essential
skills that will make you
successful as a consultant.
And that will be relevant
in your evaluation processes
as well.
So as always, if you took
any value out of this video
at all, please smash the like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
And also subscribe if you like this video,
want to see more content like that.
My name is Heinrich.
I release weekly videos
every single Saturday
here on my channel.
So thanks for watching.
As always, also a big
thanks to all the members
of the channel Firm Learning.
You're really having a
great impact on the work
here on the channel.
So thanks to all of you.
My name is Heinrich and bye-bye.
If you want to continue
your learning journey
here on the channel, I
will link in the end cards,
a video where I talk about
some sneaky tips and tricks
that consultants use that
are extremely effective
and quite helpful.
I trust this might be
relevant to you as well.
So feel free to check it out.
You'll find it here in the end card.